THAT’S WHAT THEY HOPE.
I’M GREG WITH ANGELS WATERS.
KATIE AND RON WILLIAMS.
ONCE HAD TO PUT DOWN MY LITTLE
PONY.
THE 5.
>> YESTERDAY, PRESIDENT BIDEN
SIGNED FOUR EXECUTIVE ACTIONS
BASED ON RACIAL EQUITY.
FOCUSING ON SYSTEMIC RACE ITCH
AND PRIVATE PRISONS, HOW LONGS.
COVID RELIEVE AND TRIBAL
RELATIONS.
SYSTEMIC RACISM IS WHERE YOU
LOOK.
SOLUTION IS EQUITY NOT EQUALITY.
EQUITY.
EEN JOE IS USING THE WORD.
DOES HE KNOW WHAT IT MEANS?
WHO KNOWS.
IT IS TIME FOR -- GREG EXPLAINS
STUFF THE MEDIA WISHES YOU WOULD
NOT UNDERSTAND.
NOT CRAZY ABOUT THE HAIR.
EQUALITY AS YOU KNOW, MEANS YOU
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TRY
SOMETHINGEEN IF YOU ARE BAD AT
IT.
I COULD TRY TO PLAY BASKETBALL I
WILL SUCK.
IN AMERICA I HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
TO TRY LIKE I HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BECOME AN
ELECTRICAL ENGINEER, A PIPE
FITTER.
I WOULD SUCK AT THOSE, TOO BUT
AGAINST THE LAW TO DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST ME IT IS EQUALITY OF
OPPORTUNITY NOT EQUALITY OF
OUTCOME.
.
WILL A RESERVED SPACE BASED ON
THE SINGLE AVAILABLE OF SYSTEMIC
DISCRIMINATION YOUR EQUITY
BECOMED AN ENTITLEMENT.
EQUITY NOT ONLY IGNORSE
COMPETENCE REDUCES THE TALENT
FROM OPPORTUNITY AND IGNORING
HOW PEOPLE CHOOSE DIFFERENT
THINGS.
CREATE FEMALE QUOTAS FOR OTHER
MALE DOMINATED JOBSEEN IF WOMEN
DON’T WANT THEM.
WORK PLACE DEATH FOR MEN IS 10
TIMES HIGHER THAN WOMEN DO
ACTIVISTS SEEK EQUITY THERE OR
THE CURB JOBS.
YOU WILL NEED SOMETHING TO
DECIDE WHO GETS WHAT.
THIS IS ABOUT POWER THE POWER TO
REMAKE SOCIETY AND PLACATE THE
THEORISTS WHO WORKS WITH ONE
VARIABLE, REVENGE THE FURTHEREST
FROM UNITY NOT THAT JOE WOULD
KNOW OR CARE.
>> ALL RIGHT.
JUAN I HOPE YOU PREERNLTED MY ES
APPRECIATE MY ESA IF IT IS
ALLOCATING RESOURCES HOW IS HAD
POSSIBLE WHEN EVERYONE IS
DIFFERENT YOU NEED LAWS,
QUOTEACE AND FORCE LIKE YOU
WOULD HAVE SEEN IN USSR.
IF YOU WANT EVERYBODY KWUL NEED
FORCE.
>> I WILL TELL YOU HOW I SEE
THIS, IT IS QUITE DIFFERENT
TOCHLT MY MIND.
LET’S LOOK AT THIS THIS WAY.
YOU KNOW IF YOU LOOK AT WHERE
THE CITIES IN AMERICA PUT
INCINERATORS AND DUMPS.
YOU KNOW EVEN WHEN THEY BUILD
HIGHWAY ITS GOES THROUGH
MINORITY NEIGHBORHOODS.
POOR NEIGHBORHOODS AND THE
HIGHWAYS IS KUTH THEM OFF FROM
DOWNTOWN AND THE ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY OF THE PLACES.
YOU THINK ABOUT GENTLEMAN
ASSISTANCE FOR HOUSING AND
MORTGAGES ASSISTANCE AFTER WORLD
WAR II.
STUDENT AID PROGRAMS.
EVEN FOREIGN AID AND PROMISE.
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST BLACK POEM
IN THIS COUNTRY’S HISTORY.
BIDEN, IT IS IN THE ABOUT
GUARANTEEING INDIVIDUAL OUTCOME.
IT IS SAYING, WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE STARTING POINT FOR
EVERYONE IS LEVEL.
WE ARE ON A LEVEL PLAYING FIELD.
IT IS CHILDHOOD.
POOR QUALITY SCHOOLS ARE.
HIGHER LEVELS OF UNEMPLOYMENT
AND SCARCITY OF JOBS.
THIS IS REALLY THE PROBLEM NAJOE
BIDEN IS TALKING ABOUT WHEN HE
TALKS ABOUT EQUITY MAKING SURE
GOVERNMENT IS PLAYING FAIR FOR
ALL PEOPLE.
TO ME IT IS A PAINFUL THING IT
IT IS PLAIN FOR ME TO SEE IN MY
LIFE, I THINK IT SHOULD BE PLAIN
FOR EVERYBODY TO SEE, YOU KNOW
AND I THINK WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
HOW POLICE TREAT BLACK PEOPLE
AND STUFF LIKE THAT.
IT BURNS AND HURTS DOPELY WHEN
OTHERS SAY WELL IS NOTHING GOING
ON AND IT IS MRIN FOR ME TO SEE.
>> I THINK THE THING IS
EVERYTHING YOU MENTIONED, I
WOULD AGREE W. YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT EVERYBODY HAVING EQUAL
OPPORTUNITY.
EQUITY BUILT IN THE IDEA OF --
OUTCOME, WHICH IS IMPOSSIBLE.
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE.
>> THAT’S WHAT EQUITY IS DEFINED
AS THAT IS DIFFERENT THAN
EQUALITY.
I AGREE WITH EVERYTHING YOU
SAID.
THAT’S WHAT WE WANT AND
DISCRIMINATION IS ILLEGAL AND
SHOULD BE NO MATTER HOW HARD YOU
TRY TO MAKE IT LEGAL.
THIS IS A DIFFERENT PART OF THE
EQUITY/EQUALITY THING THAT
DRIVES ME CRAZY IS WE TALK
FEMALE EQUALITY IN CERTAIN JOBS.
THEY NEVER TALK ABOUT LOGGERS OR
THOSE JOBS YOU TALK ABOUT CEO’S
AND FOOTBALL COACHES.
YOU NEVER TALK ABOUT THE ONES
WHERE MEN ARE DYING BY THE
HUNDREDS OR THOUSANDS A YEAR
>> THAT’S WHAT YOU CALL SWEAT
EQUITY.
YOU HAVE A LOMENT OF THAT.
I WAS TRYING TO REMEMBER.
YOU REMEMBER 4 MONTHS AGO THERE
WAS A CONTROVERSY THAT CAME AND
UP TRUMP WAS WILL INVOLVED AND
MIRIAM WEBSTER CHANGED THE
DEFINITION TO CONFORM WHAT THE
LEFTMENT TODAY TO BE.
I FEEL THE EQUALITY EQUITY THING
I FEEL HAVE YOU DONE A PUBLIC
SERVICE.
IT IS WAIT, WHERE THIS WORD COME
FROM.
YOU CATCH JOE BIDEN HE TALKED
ABOUT EQUITY AND HE EQUALITY AND
EQUITY TEIS NOT NATURAL.
ONE THING I DID NOT HEAR FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE, THE MAIN ISSUE
THAT YOU CAN DEAL WITH TO ENSURE
EQUALITY OF OPPORTUNITY?
WHICH WILL GET YOU TO EQUITY?
IS THAT IS EDUCATION.
K-12 EDUCATION.
AND TO JUAN’S POINT.
URE FORTUNATE TO HAVE HAD A MOM
AND THE DRIVE YOU HAD EDUCATION
YOU HAD AND MADE SO MUCH OF
YOURSELF AND YOU ARE HERE WITH
US AND WE ARE GLAD FOR THAT.
I LOOK AT THIS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND CAN CIRCUMSTANCE-12.
THAT’S HOW YOU GET TO EQUALITY.
IF YOU BELIEVE NAAMERICA IS AN
EXCEPTIONAL NATION.
BUT ALSO SO MANY AROUND THE
WORLD BELIEVE AMERICA IS
EXCEPTIONAL AND WHY?
AT LEAST IN AMERICA YOU WOULD
HAVE A SHOT.
EVERYONE WOULD HAVE A SHOT TO
TRY HARD IF YOU COME HERE AND
HAVE I DREAM, YOU HAVE A
BUSINESS IDEA.
YOU CAN MAKE IT HERE UNLIKE IN
MANY OTHER PLACE.
MOST OTHER PLACES.
>> AND TO YOUR POINT ABOUT THE
TEACHERS WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
THAT.
THE TEACHER’S UNIONS ARE NO HELP
IN THIS.
JESSE.
I WROTE THIS BECAUSE OF YOU.
I THINK YOU, YESTERDAY, SAYING
YOU DID NOT KNOW WHAT EQUITY WAS
AND WHY.
I WROTE THAT, WAS MY INSTRUCTION
HELPFUL?
JUAN MADE IT CONVINCE, GREG.
YOU MADE IT BETTER.
AND HERE IS WHY.
IF YOU READ BIDEN’S SPEECH FROM
YESTERDAY IN PRINT WHAT HE SAY
SYSTEM WHAT YOU SAID.
AND IT IS SLICK.
HE SAYS THAT ALL MEN ARE CREATED
EQUAL.
BECAUSE OF SLAVERY AND
HISTORICAL INJUSTICES SOME ARE
NOT EQUAL THEREFORE WE IMPOSE
EQUITY AND IMPOSE FAIR OUTCOME
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THESE
HISTORICAL PROBLEMS IF YOU
DISAGREE, YOU ARE DISCRIMINATING
AGAINST PEOPLE.
AND PUT SUZANNE RICE ON POINT
FOR THIS.
AND EVEN SPELLS HOW THE WHO HE
IS TALKING B. RACIAL MINORITIES
AND LEGISLATION MINORITIES.
INDIANS AND POEM IN PROTECTED
CLASSES.
AND HE SPELLS OUT HOW HE WILL DO
IT, GREG.
HE SAYS HOUSING IS A RIGHT.
FREE HOUSING.
HE WANTS TO HAVE UNIVERSAL
PRE-K.
HE WANTS CERTAIN POEM TOM HAVE
ACCESS TO CERTAIN LOANS AND
UNIVERSITIES GET SPECIAL PERKS.
WANTS TO FEDERALIZE THE VOTING
SYSTEM IN THIS COUNTRY.
GARNT LEVELS OF HEALTH CARE.
IF YOU ARE LOOKING AT THAT, THAT
LOOKS LIKE BACK DOOR SOCIALISM.
AND LOOKS LIKE TO SOME PEOPLE
LIKE IT IS BACK DOOR
REPARATIONS.
YOU CAN’T SAY THAT YET BUT THE
WAY IT IS SO VAGUE, IT LEADS TO
YOU BELIEVE, YEA, I’M FOR THIS
AND THAT AND I WANT EVERYONE TO
BE PROSPEROUS.
WHEN YOU SEE THAT SUSAN ROYCE IS
IN CHARGE AND PICKING WINNERS
AND LOSERS WITH LAWYERS AND
BUREAUCRATS AND DESTROY YOU IF
YOU GET IN YOUR WAY THAT DOES
NOT SOUNDUNE FIGHTING.
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS SO BIG AND
POWERFUL AND HAS THE ARM OF THE
D. JUSTICE THIS AFFECTS HIRING.
AFFECTS FIRING.
AFFECTS BUYING, SELLING,
CONTRACTS AND AFFECTS
EVERYTHING.
WHEN YOU LOOK BACK AND SEE THIS
MIGHT DESTROY THE DOLLAR TELL
SPEND TRIYONS.
WHY ARE WE DOING THIS?
DONALD TRUMP’S AMERICA FIRST
AGENDA LOWERED THE BLACK POVERTY
RATE.
HAD THE BLACK JOB ELSE RATE THE
LOWEST LEVEL EVER WHY WOULD YOU
NOT WANT THAT CAPITOLISTIC
APPROACH?
THEY WANT SOCIAL SXICHL THEM TO
BE IN CHARGE.
THAT’S THE PROBLEM.
TELLMIC THEM FEEL BETTER BUT IT
WILL NOT WORK.
>> KATIE, I THINK THE IDEA OF
CENT RIFT JOE BIDEN LASTED 24
HOURS.
THIS IS AS FAR AS FROM THE
CENTER YOU CAN GET.
>> YEA.
>> YOU WERE WARNED.
GREG, THE PROBLEM WITH EQUALITY
OF OPPORTUNITY.
EQUITY REQUIRES YOU DISCRIMINATE
AGAINST CERTAIN GROUPS.
WE SAW THIS WITH HARVARD
DISCRIMINATING AGAINST ASIAN
STUDENTS.
HAVE YOU TO LOOK AT IT IN THE
BROADER PICTURE IT IS TALKED
ABOUT IN THE NARROW LEFT-HAND
LANES OF RACE.
WE HAVE SEEN THE MAYOR OF
BALTIMORE WHO IS BLACK.
MAYOR OF CHICAGO IS BLACK.
WHEN YOU BREAK IT DOWN BY
POSSIBLE LAGZ IT LOOKS LIKE A
POLITICAL CLASS ISSUE THAN A
RACE ISSUE THERE IS NO
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SPENDING TRILLIONS
WITH NO RETURN ON INVESTMENTS.
YOU HAVE THE TEACHER’S UNIONS
NOT ALLOWING FOR SCHOOL CHOICE
ENABLES THE CYCLE OF POVERTY IN
THE ACCOMPLICE THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT PRETENDS THEY ARE
DOING SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
>> UP NEXT THE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE